what are we doing I don't like this
[Music]
shows we alike
welcome to wfe episode numero 9 so let's
talk about destiny - what the dlc what
we think is going to happen the dlc
where it's going and yeah discuss it so
you're pretty knowledgeable on you're
always up on the news I'm not you know
yeah I know I know a little bit they
they released the trailer for I think
it's cursive of Osiris I think the
biggest thing with it
and Bungie usually does a good job they
it's hard to hit every [ __ ] note but
they do a good job of listening to the
community with like you know what they
need to change like I said listen too
much no because like Steve was talking
about they know they need to keep their
player base so they've got to listen to
people because if they don't
nobody's gonna play the [ __ ] game you
know the weapons the MA the weapons
because they've a Luke Smith vaguely
said we understand the duplicates are
like that's annoying
like you know you keep getting the same
[ __ ] gun so they said they they want
to keep the fixed roles but they want to
make it their a reason to get those
duplicates for like change it like the
same gun over because you know it's
fixed rules so it's always the same
rules Orioles they they said you know
they want to make it so you get those
multiple guns that you can there's a
reason for it so that's what that goes
into the
the the mod system because I think the
mod systems like it's a good idea but
they need to do more with it
like I said make the make the legendary
weapon mods a perk so you get to pick
you have a bunch of different perks from
these mods you get to pick one specific
one that you want on that gun that goes
for your play style you know what I'm
saying if I'm using the hand can and I
want luck in the chamber I get to put
that you know I can grind for that mod
and then switch that out what do you
think they're gonna have those like luck
or the chamber drops and I I don't know
luck in the chamber you know by its I
don't know but just perks in general
yeah you know so that way actually are
doing I think they're hinting they're
hinting at it I'm looking at something
right now as they're saying something
about that they're hinting at it so like
I'm thinking that that's what they're
gonna do with the mod so that way they
can keep the fixed roles which is fine
if I get to customize my gun a little
bit more so like that's that's what I'm
hoping from are for and the expansion
that way it just makes the grind a
little bit more but um also I'm just
excited for this expansion because it's
gonna be vex themed so it's gonna be you
like the veil I love I love the vex
start over yeah thanks for the first the
vex and they said like raid material so
they have it come out and said that
there is a raid but they said raid
content so I'm not sure how to take that
there are some people thinking that
they're gonna do a legit horde mode like
a zombie like see how many levels but
but but I was like when you do public
events right now it's fun when there's
like seven people there love that yeah
but like I think it would be cool to
have the Dreadnought you could do that
remember have a have a horde mode like
that that doesn't cap but the goal is to
see how high you can get what number you
can get to and the enemies get stronger
and stronger and stronger so I mean I'd
be cool with that there's other people
saying that because they took a voice
clip of what they say in the trailer
saying that you return to the vault of
glass so I'm not sure
no I'm not sure if that's not evening a
lot of people want ball two glasses team
and come back I would rather have a new
rate just so it's new well if they
remastered and made the vault different
I'd be all know but going back to the
vault of glass doesn't mean that it just
it could be rain rain starts at the
vault imply right right right I'm
looking forward to you know the
disappointment of not being at the
highest light level yeah it just being
like I can't get there and I just like
that feeling I'm just like I don't have
like you know I don't have a character
that's three or five years I don't
either
I am in real 397 I can get it 305 guy
actually if I like I have to grab this
gun and I had to you know have this
configuration that I don't necessarily
like yeah but that's the what I'm
looking forward to this being like
that's my reason for playing I like the
old system of infusing I don't like this
other no good you have to you can't you
can't just you have to make sure it's
the same model gun name weapon you can't
infuse like a pulse into an auto or oh
yeah that's have to scale to Scott right
like that that's part of making you
grind yeah it the grind wouldn't be
there if they did that you'd be 305
right away but I mean well I don't like
that they made it so you can't like take
a hunter helmet and if you bring a [ __ ]
back yeah it's like really hard to but
again and that's why I messed the grime
that's why I made three hunters because
all my gears I don't I don't you think
it was hunters masterclass T I got a
tattooed on my [ __ ] skin I'm gonna
make a hunter but no not in this game I
only have a warlock you only use Titans
I'm gonna make a hunter I just first
character up to 305 which I just you you
make like you make all your characters
right away and then you yeah I do you
know what I'm saying yeah I made a mall
I mean and what I realized what I would
do now though is like if I had to do it
again like I would make like like right
now let's say if I want to make a
different warlock I would put all my
warlock stuff in the vault now I know
now I know how I want to do it because
you know you can rank it up faster that
way I started with a Titan and it
forever you know you know to rank up in
the other characters cuz I already had
two guns and I would just give it to
them and then you know I get to 20 write
it so I know I know how to do it that
might be fun
I just I like the story it's just
tedious yeah yeah well you guys never
mentioned like the new powerful engrams
that's new right powerful engrams
powering them yeah the ones that are
like the good Engram drops they never
had that in Destin from the vendor's you
mean yeah just all-around powerful
engrams the Purple's
not behind the luminous the luminous
right so you guys think about that [ __ ]
well the look the luminous is the ever
versus it ain't it
yeah that's the Brighton gram no but the
powerful engrams that was there at the
purple legendaries but that come with
like a mod on them or know the ones that
drop high like three or five or three at
like 300 that's from the raid or some
challenges it doesn't always like even
sometimes Hawthorne the clan rewards
it'll drop something like really nah
you're not high enough or something like
that but you know I I'm looking forward
to that you know and then so they said
the raid content but what the hell does
that mean see that's the thing because
just say a raid if it's a raid raid
that's the thing that's why people do
ask people people are speculating people
are speculating wondering well they're
saying that that's why they're saying
like they don't know if it's a for-sure
raid because most of the time they say
new raid yeah well this time they're
saying raid content so you don't yeah
but um I don't want to do the right I
don't care now they said hey I know how
you feel good so frustrating okay I
don't need that gear once you get it I
agree get like the wild wolf she ate the
wild wood I just I I understand like
getting their group together is hard and
I'm not I'm not a big rapey I have a
group we have a nice yeah well none of
us know how to do it
the thing to do now I know how to do it
do you really remember we once we
figured it out we would do it all the
time how come I don't feel that way with
this game well the feeling cuz your
hands ain't on dude no no no I play yeah
but you don't play with us yeah dude I
mean you haven't played as much and but
here's the thing to be honest Eve when I
did it with these guys like the only
thing that difficult is the guys telling
you where to go with the dogs that part
that I was doing when I that we recorded
is actually one of the hardest things
and aim and it was it was pretty like
when we got because I said okay guys I'm
gonna give this to
chronicity of your team here now I was I
was I was big on that too I'm not I'm
not big on the race dude but I'll say I
was I was like I was tired I'm like I'm
gonna give it I'm gonna give him two
tries
he said we Pikachu winners wait man when
my mad when we do math when we played
with him and shoot the [ __ ] I want to
shoot things when we when we played with
him and Pikachu in that group we had for
like two hours went by like nothing
because we got it it was my beat on
everything in one or two yeah it was fun
okay what are the other ones I'm not
gonna play so just tell me what the
other you should do you even care for
the raid you don't care I don't care if
I have people doing it I'll do it
but like I don't I'm not like
frustrating
it's fun it's different it's not gonna
be like 320 yeah that's that's the
problem if it's a 320 like you you have
to do the rate cuz the light level yeah
but it's gonna happen though what are
you gonna add new raid content and
you're gonna have to do the raid again
because now the new raid gear is gonna
draw higher it's after the DLC after the
first deal see the game is always better
because of that you know what I like
wall is fun this is this is where they
drop the ball and prestige I think the
prestige raid you get different armor
but there's no different weapons which
people were complaining about they got
right is the nightfall gave them that
they got that shit's hard they got the
night falls hard they got the prestige
raid but now they're adding challenges
into the right now too so like the
challenge this week was the the pools
like what's the pools yeah it's like the
relay race thing where like the the big
guys with the swords jump out of the
pools yes I don't know but I mean going
back to it like I'm not a big I'm I'll
contest dude I'm a pvp guy I'd rather
play PvP but we did that raid and like I
said I was tired I had to hours went by
like nothing cuz when you get it and you
you see you have chemistry and it's
going to work the problem with the race
very in the prison well when we when we
all do it we never get further like it's
once it starts going bad everybody said
nobody gives a [ __ ]
it just takes one person lose
concentration yeah and nobody gives one
person little gas so then it's like a
big waste of time but when you see when
you see the teams starting to work
together and you're getting further then
you're like okay we got this [ __ ] we
get so it gets you enthusiastic our
problem is morale I think in our [ __ ]
yeah like once we get down what starts
out to raise like I don't what are we
doing I don't like this who wants to do
this no cuz you're the first one you can
see this and then this happens
I said I said I said Google [ __ ] and
like look at videos and I hate thanks
all about yeah I said it like I said I
wish they would make a raid where it's
just shooting a bunch of people really
[ __ ] hard just make you're really
[ __ ] hard oh my god [ __ ]
I agree I agree cuz there's a brawls
like exploding thralls that run and you
have to judge well let's go back to so
the next DLC there's you're saying soon
they're gonna bring PvP where it's
actually you can match against other
friends and people oh yeah so they're
they're bringing back private match
which is [ __ ] huge which actually be
fun to do with teams like if we had
teams of four against like arrows skies
of four yeah yeah that kind of beacons
cabin because Gavin's I respect his game
but you got the higher KD know you might
take Frank down right dude I think you
might be able to take now you know I do
think you could take me now my shits
just flawed I'm just you real
I just hide what the euros and I then it
comes out but they cheap cheap the next
DLC though I think it the light are the
power or whatever it goes up to 325 and
then they're gonna have five levels that
you go so like you know your level 20
you get five more levels you advanced
well so it's gonna go to level 25 and
then the power then we're gonna add a
story yeah
that's why they're doing it because they
want you to level up through the story
do you like look at this is my this is
my only complaint with PvP they should
have like a hundred modes you get you
know not just those five things I agree
yeah that should add more modes that's a
choice that's my point like yeah like I
don't like that they took away modes
yeah when they have modes we always
still played only we only played control
it's like having cable you don't go to
Animal Planet
I like I said here we go she competitive
is not even that's what we always play
quickly well they're just fun or game
well well and like I like survival I
like survival but it goes back to me
being like a DD I hate dying and then
waiting wait that's why I like even
trials when it's countdown it's just I
come get your revive yeah okay Craig is
the worst my big all right now we're
going back in episode you said it the
best you like he's not aware of his
awareness is not there you know that
you're dead or like we're going 100% no
fan this goes back to agreements that I
have right you said that you said we
were playing this right we're playing
away today we were playing the other day
and we got into a heated thing trial and
playing trials is on eternity I think
maybe the first or second week it felt
like an eternity but yeah it really did
because I'm telling Craig to move you
video now I'm knowing
telling Craig to move with me and team
shot okay all right Craig so so here we
go we're both coming up I poke out I'm
pushing I push out Craig is behind this
corner amen I get I get worse
I get worse by two people amen I die he
forgets that I become a third person
view I can see around corners he says I
go Craig shoot him
he's like I'm shooting him what he means
is he's scoping past this corner waiting
for them to come so he's shooting but
he's not [ __ ] hitting it so I'm yes
I'm pressing I guys if it was [ __ ]
if there's two people on me and I'm one
real low health down if you're shooting
with me they should both be dead they
shouldn't both they both survive or heal
sir they both survived opposite he'll go
some different direction well I know if
I push it with somebody I push no way
don't do that let's go there's two
different comments here one is pushing
okay go let's push him with coke I was
know you guys weren't there so this was
me and coke fried Pikachu I don't know
who knows and and I was next to coke the
problem was he got tagged and dies when
he gets when he gets killed he gets
pissed no matter what happens I was
shooting at those guys I was shooting at
those guys I was not around the corner
he thinks I was because I don't know
where he was when he saw me after he
died listen either either that class
girlfriend either Craig is is lying
right now
or he is or he is super terrible at this
game because
okay now listen I'm listening this this
word words are just making me down oh if
we're truly team shooting right I got
two people shooting me I'm shooting one
of the guys that's team shooting night
and I get a lot worse if we're team
shooting that guy should be dead if I
get a guy down
you're red took like this much health
what he's saying Craig this can I listen
I get him down to a red red bar I know I
get him down to a red bar I I'm not mad
that I died I would be happy even if he
does know even if he dies sorry let's
say that's whatever saying if shoot him
once with your mighty in his Yogi's
there well yeah here's the thing I
wouldn't be as mad if if we both push
and okay they kill both of us but we get
one down we don't get one we're pushing
one guy yes I did I agree that's why I'm
he's very belay that thousand games bro
bro I'm telling our kid winner I see
where's your bitching about it like
you're there you haven't play with us in
seven months
flexion I know what he's coming from you
let's talk about Sonya we were playing
you guys you would coke with Gavin and
me and you just weren't even next to
coke what are you talking about he knows
you were not anywhere he was like on red
zone right now he's like he's so close
to the red zone
each brother brings up just the trophy
he had when he would wrestle it just
slowly comes up in the background no no
we're not just just to be on the record
Craig was behind the wall
Craig team shot the wall yeah I'm not
gonna defend that I'm not good at the
game cuz we know this and nobody was
going I'm not I'm not saying that Coke
does sometimes though I can't stand
shooting he's there with you for a
second and all of a sudden he's gone
then you die and he pops out and kills
the guy right out this super or
something yeah now sometimes you get a
recharge shield
no thank you oh but if you're gonna dive
with the cheap shot listen because
listen you do right set up a listen
listen when we're playing like when I'm
telling a picture when I'm telling Craig
we need to push we need to push all I
will push Griffin is never an appoint
where he's like art coke let's put
Griffin puts himself in terrible
position where he does your asses into
power mo [ __ ]
we're both of the pages may I steal it
from it same a coke don't act like
you're shooting simply something is out
of your peripheral vision you're like oh
look Griffin's over there's an hour at
my default upon you
coincidence that I just happen to be
there I don't know where they spawn
Frank help me did you know where they
spawned earlier well not only that not
only that I don't know where they
spawned I don't look he was listen who's
like Columbo he did say just one more
thing I like how he said like I said two
episodes ago like it wasn't an hour and
a half ago these point two though I'm
defending you right now to Steve's point
because I'm gonna accuse Craig in this
because he says I'm always going for it
you spawn on your allies so when when
we're dead
we spawn where you guys are at so if
someone's hoarding the power and we
spawn next to it next to them yeah
that's what happened cuz the maps are
little [ __ ] thank you Craig's always
like you folks going for it like I spawn
right next to you I'm gonna go for it I
go for it if it's coming up well I mean
like we all have our shortcomings I
think some of us submit to him some of
us don't
but that mean I mean game play speaks
for itself I mean I feel like if you
have a bad game just open any Guinness
Premiership I if I if I lost by lost
sleep playing with you guys I would get
no [ __ ] sleep
worst friend was ever no you don't I
think keeps him up when I would I beat
him once and I get all happy about it we
know the other night we were hosted it
you can find it on worst fire team ever
into the ground
we were dominated coke no Steve Steve
Steve
you were actually playing you were
playing at his house but he was talking
trash about my Katie because I think I
had a Laura KD the game before the next
game I went 31 you know that is true I
saw that that was like all right I gotta
go to bed and then I just remember like
the text as I'm going to sleep it's like
never four candles like are some [ __ ]
went down someone said something to piss
coke off cuz you know thirty one cuz you
know why cuz sandy handy over here now
we call them sandy he rubs people the
wrong way
[Laughter]
hockey coach you don't have a lot of
time left so let's just I actually want
to switch it up general Craig's what you
want to go home I'm sorry you want to go
to outside Craig I wish it off strong
but no I wanted to just talk about you
know like stuff that we like right now
stuff that's going on like what time I
shows or movies we just saw Thor yeah we
saw Thor do you ever seen I didn't see
it did you see it it's really funny that
was funny I thought it was one of the
more funny Marvel movies very
entertaining you know along with all the
like you know good acting right put it
the best way though it was like Thor
meets Galaxy guardians of galaxy yeah
that kind of like it was very stylistic
and like there's a lot of fun yeah the
music is great I thought it was really
fun I thought I liked this version of
the Honka halt yeah
he was really fun yeah and he's actually
funny and I feel like he was there's a
lot of times he's like that brooding
like I'm gonna be the whole condemned he
was kind of fun right right right I
thought this was like it was a really
entertaining movie I'd see it again yeah
I like that so Frank was in San Marcos
and we should go see it with Frank again
I would Steve the trophy will be hey
let's go on a TV series yeah by the way
I have a 4k TV you know I mean beautiful
and it's like it's being it's being
streamed 4k it looks fantastic
yeah I'll even get to the part of the
robots I'm just talking you know what
these kids are like the standard of
acting and it goes when you think of kid
actors now I go
stranger things Anakin Skywalker that's
like the worst yeah the best is stranger
things and the worst is like thank you
good one I love right now that kind of
trying to get Stevie into his bite and
you watch it Vice Principals
have you watched big mouth I don't know
if that Steve's thing I have no so he
loves he loves that kind of stuff I know
it Steve he'd love Walter Goggins and
he'd loved the grandma oh don't want to
ruin it for him but he loved that other
guy that something something the two
leads yeah he's so I just saw him in
hateful eight fantastic hateful eight
amazing really good movie I but I think
in Vice Principals he's even better I
think his hair is so good Zoe I like
Danny I'm a big adventure series I keep
hearing about mind hundred oh good it's
it's basically like it's right before
they figure out what like a serial
killer is or like they like before they
like like they yeah before they create
the term and then like start getting
into like psychology of a killer and
stuff so like they go in the interview a
lot of like Sirico so you get to see
like Edie Kemper and then like what's
fiction right no it's well it's like
like historical fiction in the sense so
it's like the book is based on his real
but then they like TV show they kind of
like it's really good because I know if
you know Edie Kemper who was a real
serial killer who cut his mom's head off
and [ __ ] her neck he when he was in
know that it's not like I'm a shoot me
and Hannah's a huge serial killer family
but that dude when he was in prison he
ended up getting hired to do all the
voice work for like books I mean I got a
big neck
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I think soon like that black mare season
four I'm that's like that's Twilight
Zone for this generation yeah but like
what the tech detect aspect yeah well
the episode I really enjoyed in black
mare was the one about the like where
you could replay things in your head and
you know and you know you thought the
guy was being paranoid and what the take
I love that they did was that he was
correct right and so that so you had
this thing where it's like damn do you
want to know all the information right
like you want to have that like we could
prove that your girl cheated on you or
you can see that everything it's like do
you want that kind of like ah every
episode I mean a lot of them are just
amazing like the upload one is my
favorite also I love that actress yeah
oh yeah that was great
I just like to always like having to be
like give me a five I love it because
like yeah people cuz I feel like that's
a part of where where yeah exactly
that's where we're going we're like
everybody's judged on like you know
social media for example yeah I freak
out when someone follows me that I like
or that I follow like it's someone like
like status they tweet I thought enough
you guys did you guys even watch
Handmaid's Tale I did I watched the
first season and I liked it I'm not into
women I'm just kidding now me and the
fiance watch it I thought that was a
really good one here's the thing with
all that is like it does worry me that
all these shows are so dark
yeah like it because a lot of times like
TV reflects like people in society yeah
well that's why that show was so popular
is because you know you have Trump in
office and so it's kind of like really
out there right and so you have this
idea in this in this you know classic
book right so now people think this guy
could this actually happen right it's
good actually right exactly that's
that's why you get their fear of like
but I feel like we've really gotten to
like a lot of shows are about just
opions and it's a little it's it's it
does make you worry a little I think
well it's the fear no you want some
positivity which is why I watch big
mouths no what's that about the big it's
basically just about like kids in like
middle school going through puberty yeah
yeah yeah Larry
and it's so funny because they have like
like like the hormone monsters and like
John Mulaney is great in a Nick Kroll is
fantastic and there's a lot of really
good comedians that are doing the voices
for it so that was really good that's
done really well the lead in that who
plays like the dumb guy as he freakin
kills
he's funny the stoner so [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's like making a mock a
mockumentary I just started watching zoo
with my girlfriend and it was actually
pretty interesting show what does it
mean that way it's just like it's a
network show that's like on CBS or
whatever it's about how the animals are
starting to think and they gonna take
over the world
you know but it's just like it's just
like a very and you know interesting you
know some good TV I have some guilty
pleasures like I like Supergirl I think
that acting on Supergirl was great all
right guys it's the end of this
[ __ ] what about anything you're
looking forward to I mean obviously I
said bleep most recent Star Wars trailer
I really like a lot yeah I like I like
because I'm like Mark Hamill oh I just
wasn't having him like I don't know why
they did what they did in the last movie
they shouldn't they shouldn't have
revealed him like that because it was it
was anticlimactic we know who the [ __ ]
does he know you don't like you know the
big Jedi hoodie reveal but we know it's
Luke Skywalker's all right it's like
what are you trying to like so where
they show the new trailer I want to see
oh you got a look at it it's great bro
no because I like this whole idea that
Luke Skywalker's like hey just Jedi [ __ ]
ain't too good and like I'm not gonna
get fooled again yeah yeah but he's like
this old man who's like he's over it I
like that I just don't like it looks too
scared of everything because you know
what happened he said he seen the word
[ __ ] man yeah but he saw he saw [ __ ]
his friend he saw his friend his
father's [ __ ] go nuts
his father died ok just try to say and
he never had the relationship he wanted
to have with his father and then he's
trying to train his best friend's kid
and his enemies arcs on he's like and
he's like this [ __ ] they're still
building Death Star's yeah thought we
beat these [ __ ] there's a
yesterday there's a new there's another
one a little mini on this two movies
coming out that I [ __ ] want to watch
so goddamn New Mutants the wall also a
brawl in cellblock 99 with [ __ ] Vince
Vaughn have you seen that no he'd like
plays like this [ __ ] crazy like like
[ __ ] Patriot kind of dude and he like
has to go to prison [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
nuts the beginning of him was just
beating the [ __ ] out of a [ __ ] Toyota
it's crazy
is it a comedy no it is not a college
it's like him going to prison then the
other movie that's coming out is called
shot callers and it's the dude from Game
of Thrones Jamie Lannister and that's
about him going to prison and then him
living in prison and then him having to
like become like to join the like he has
to join one of the gangs to like survive
and then [ __ ] just goes downhill what
does that I think that drops in a few
months that she looks amazing
you know you're gonna find out a lot of
stuff not just video games from worth
bar team as far team ever has a lot of
opinions about things and we're pretty
we've turned into pretty good friends
and you know I think that keep coming
with us on this adventure and you're
gonna get some great information and
have some great times now and chicken
and now for the chicken
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]